PROFESSOR: Let's
do a work check.
So main check.
If integral psi star x t0,
psi x t0 dx is equal to 1
at t equal to t0,
as we say there,
then it must hold for later
times, t greater than t0.
This is what we want to
check, or verify, or prove.
Now, to do it, we're
going to take our time.
So it's not going to happen in
five minutes, not 10 minutes,
maybe not even half an hour.
Not because it's
so difficult. It's
because there's so
many things that one
can say in between
that teach you
a lot about quantum mechanics.
So we're going to
take our time here.
So we're going to first rewrite
it with better notation.
So we'll define rho
of x and t, which
is going to be called
the probability density.
And it's nothing else than
what you would expect, psi star
of x and t, psi of x and t.
It's a probability density.
You know that has the
right interpretation,
it's psi squared.
And that's the kind of thing
that integrated over space
gives you the total probability.
So this is a
positive number given
by this quantity is called
the probability density.
Fine.
What do we know about
this probability density
that we're trying to
find about its integral?
So define next N of t to be the
integral of rho of x and t dx.
Integrate this
probability density
throughout space, and that's
going to give you N of t.
Now, what do we know?
We know that N of t, or
let's assume that N of t0
is equal to 1.
N is that normalization.
It's that total integral
of the probability
what had to be equal to 1.
Well, let's assume N
at t0 is equal to 1.
That's good.
The question is, will
the Schrodinger equation
guarantee that--
and here's the claim--
dN dt is equal to 0?
Will the Schrodinger
equation guarantee this?
If the Schrodinger
equation guarantees
that this derivative
is, indeed, zero,
then we're in good business.
Because the derivative
is zero, the value's 1,
will remain 1 forever.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: May I ask
why you specified
for t greater than t0?
Well, I don't have to specify
for t greater than t naught.
I could do it for all t
different than t naught.
But if I say this way, as
imagining that somebody
prepares the system
at some time,
t naught, and maybe the system
didn't exist for other times
below.
Now, if a system
existed for long time
and you look at it at t naught,
then certainly the Schrodinger
equation should imply
that it works later
and it works before.
So it's not really necessary,
but no loss of generality.
OK, so that's it.
Will it guarantee that?
Well, that's our thing to do.
So let's begin the work by doing
a little bit of a calculation.
And so what do we need to do?
We need to find the
derivative of this quantity.
So what is this derivative of N
dN dt will be the integral d dt
of rho of x and t dx.
So I went here and
brought in the d dt, which
became a partial derivative.
Because this is just a
function of t, but inside here,
there's a function of
t and a function of x.
So I must make clear that
I'm just differentiating t.
So is d dt of rho.
And now we can write
it as integral dx.
What this rho?
Psi star psi.
So we would have d dt of psi
star times psi plus psi star
d dt of psi.
OK.
And here you see, if you
were waiting for that,
that the Schrodinger
equation has to be necessary.
Because we have the psi dt.
And that information is there
with Schrodinger's equation.
So let's do that.
So what do we have?
ih bar d psi dt equal h psi.
We'll write it like
that for the time being
without copying all what h is.
That would take a lot of time.
And from this equation,
you can find immediately
that d psi dt is minus
i over h bar h hat psi.
Now we need to complex
conjugate this equation,
and that is always
a little more scary.
Actually, the way
to do this in a way
that you never get into
scary or strange things.
So let me take the complex
conjugate of this equation.
Here I would have i
goes to minus i h bar,
and now I would have--
we can go very slow--
d psi dt star equals, and then
I'll be simple minded here.
I think it's the best.
I'll just start the
right hand side.
I start the left hand side
and start the right hand side.
Now here, the complex conjugate
of a derivative, in this case
I want to clarify what it is.
It's just the derivative
of the complex conjugate.
So this is minus ih
bar d/dt of psi star
equals h hat psi
star, that's fine.
And from here, if I multiply
again by i divided by h bar,
we get d psi star dt is equal
to i over h star h hat psi star.
We obtain this useful formula
and this useful formula,
and both go into our
calculation of dN dt.
So what do we have here?
dN dt equals integral dx, and
I will put an i over h bar,
I think, here.
Yes.
i over h bar.
Look at this term first.
We have i over h
bar, h psi star psi.
And the second term
involves a d psi dt that
comes with an opposite sign.
Same factor of i over h bar,
so minus psi star h psi.
So the virtue of what
we've done so far
is that it doesn't
look so bad yet.
And looks relatively clean, and
it's very suggestive, actually.
So what's happening?
We want to show that
dN dt is equal to 0.
Now, are we going to be
able to show that simply
that to do a lot of algebra
and say, oh, it's 0?
Well, it's kind of
going to work that way,
but we're going to
do the work and we're
going to get to dN dt being
an integral of something.
And it's just not
going to look like 0,
but it will be
manipulated in such a way
that you can argue it's 0
using the boundary condition.
So it's kind of interesting
how it's going to work.
But here structurally,
you see what
must happen for this
calculation to succeed.
So we need for this to be 0.
We need the following
thing to happen.
The integral of h
hat psi star psi
be equal to the integral
of psi star h psi.
And I should write the dx's.
They are there.
So this would guarantee
that dN dt is equal to 0.
So that's a very nice
statement, and it's kind of nice
is that you have one
function starred,
one function non-starred.
The h is where the function
needs to be starred,
but on the other
side of the equation,
the h is on the other side.
So you've kind of moved the
h from the complex conjugated
function to the non-complex
conjugated function.
From the first function
to this second function.
And that's a very nice thing
to demand of the Hamiltonian.
So actually what
seems to be happening
is that this conservation
of probability
will work if your
Hamiltonian is good enough
to do something like this.
And this is a nice formula,
it's a famous formula.
This is true if H is
a Hermitian operator.
It's a very interesting
new name that
shows up that an
operator being Hermitian.
So this is what I
was promising you,
that we're going to
do this, and we're
going to be learning all kinds
of funny things as it happens.
So what is it for a
Hermitian operator?
Well, a Hermitian
operator, H, would actually
satisfy the following.
That the integral,
H psi 1 star psi 2
is equal to the integral
of psi 1 star H psi 2.
So an operator is said to be
Hermitian if you can move it
from the first part to the
second part in this sense,
and with two
different functions.
So this should be possible
to do if an operator is
to be called Hermitian.
Now, of course, if it holds
for two arbitrary functions,
it holds when the two functions
are the same, in this case.
So what we need is
a particular case
of the condition of hermiticity.
Hermiticity simply means that
the operator does this thing.
Any two functions that you put
here, this equality is true.
Now if you ask yourself, how
do I even understand that?
What allows me to move the H
from one side to the other?
We'll see it very soon.
But it's the fact that H
has second derivatives,
and maybe you can
integrate them by parts
and move the derivatives
from the psi 1 to the psi 2,
and do all kinds of things.
But you should try to think at
this moment structurally, what
kind of objects you have, what
kind of properties you have.
And the objects
are this operator
that controls the
time evolution, called
the Hamiltonian.
And if I want probability
interpretation to make sense,
we need this equality, which is
a consequence of hermiticity.
Now, I'll maybe use a
little of this blackboard.
I haven't used it much before.
In terms of Hermitian
operators, I'm
almost there with a definition
of a Hermitian operator.
I haven't quite given it to
you, but let's let state it,
given that we're already in
this discussion of hermiticity.
So this is what is called the
Hermitian operator, does that.
But in general, rho,
given an operator T,
one defines its hermitian
conjugate P dagger as follows.
So you have the
integral of psi 1 star T
psi 2, and that must be
rearranged until it looks
like T dagger psi 1 star psi 2.
Now, these things
are the beginning
of a whole set of ideas that are
terribly important in quantum
mechanics.
Hermitian operators, or
eigenvalues and eigenvectors.
So it's going to take
a little time for you
to get accustomed to them.
But this is the beginning.
You will explore a little
bit of these things
in future homework, and
start getting familiar.
For now, it looks very
strange and unmotivated.
Maybe you will see that
that will change soon, even
throughout today's lecture.
So this is the
Hermitian conjugate.
So if you want to calculate
the Hermitian conjugate,
you must start with this thing,
and start doing manipulations
to clean up the psi 2,
have nothing at the psi 2,
everything acting on
psi 1, and that thing
is called the dagger.
And then finally, T is Hermitian
if T dagger is equal to T.
So its Hermitian
conjugate is itself.
It's almost like people
say a real number is
a number whose complex
conjugate is equal to itself.
So a Hermitian operator is
one whose Hermitian conjugate
is equal to itself, and
you see if T is Hermitian,
well then it's back to T
and T in both places, which
is what we've been saying here.
This is a Hermitian operator.